Pro Football Hall of Famer Michael Irvin
Heather here on the Rich Eisen show so
this is just like a fox sports is this a
best damn sports show period reunion
right now first place I saw J door over
there where here was this when I used to
love man I used to love seeing Jay over
he come on the show all the time over
there yeah
rich let me tell you what I love man you
know what when I pull up it I see your
new banner you know when you gotta walk
the thing when you walk in and you got
rid you see see this right here you see
you little logo right here yes and I
thought about this I said see this is
what a white guy does okay you cool a
brother shoot you gotta see my face oh
my feet are you gonna whip you gotta see
me see you kick me any white guy rich
but I brother I gotta make sure you know
that's me you know what I mean it's just
different man I like that you had that
humble like that I just say are you are
you saying my running style is not
unique in itself for me you know black
guys the mug and the photo with no show
because I mentioned I really do believe
that we got a weather that's what I love
about younger kids to date like my son
and his best friend they they they they
they joke around and have fun they don't
look at the differences they accentuate
the differences and I think that's where
we're headed hopefully with this guy we
just got
moving that way but stuff for me to have
this conversation right now with the
three pound Yorkie sitting on my desk so
now you guys didn't work you guys did
work together at Fox Sports right what
what other movies you wish I was an old
Jerry Maguire I love watching them I
love I love all his work and love what
he does I was on I've been a big fan of
his for it forever he's a funny dude now
he's a funny dude
I called him oh my god and Deacon Jones
was part of the mix with you guys right
dee dee the man Deacon Jones was Jones
went to see you do stand-up yeah okay
I'm 30 and I come onstage he goes he's
just like coughing so hard he's got like
didn't that Newport 100 yeah he doesn't
like go to jail like Lenny Bruce cuz I
was again and somebody goes who and he
goes who mother ever I'm still a threat
he's like hey oh it was like six dudes
he goes hey man I'm still threat man
they went fast until he left man deke
was he was just a man man I got a chance
to go to a funeral but but but being
with him at the Hall of Fame every year
tip he still took over the room he took
over the room the year that I told the
story before I'll tell it again here the
year that Shannon Sharpe went in and
Sterling was the one who is his
presenter and slipped the gold jacket on
him on the Friday night ceremony and the
two of them embraced and cried on each
other's shoulders and it was a really
moving touching moment that the local
newspaper they can't repository blew up
it was the full front-page picture of
that newspaper that day and I walked
into the hotel and deccan her in front
of them held the newspaper up and he's
like you guys are just I can't use the
words that he says he's right there's no
crying you know oh my god he goes you
gonna do this today am I gonna be
sitting up there on this on the stage
for three hours you imagine being in the
locker room that guys what we do to miss
key luncheon that I sit around I look
around us man it would have been
something if I could have had deacon in
a locker room with Lawrence Taylor guys
like Ray Nitschke you know what I mean
these are dudes they just John Salley my
guys our guy - sounds good to me just
too tall to be an actor I went through a
deacons house and he's giving out a
scholarship for it was the Deacon Jones
foundation like Madsen was there all
these Hall of Famers men like don't ask
him what's in his bag I'm like well now
I got it
like I said we said I love you to each
other I love them you know you love we
love you your dad almost and didn't grab
me my machete goes like 180 like I was
doing incline press you know like my dad
Marty with the gut he just don't I was
in the back station
yeah and never know that I couldn't and
then he sit at the table in his backyard
you know in like the Anaheim Hills and
he's got like dolphin shorts and like
them John stocked the extra mediums that
John Stockton and he's got he's like
burns on his legs I go how'd you get
those bonds on your legs and he goes
Korea man I don't like to talk about it
I'm like whoosh and I go in the house I
go Elizabeth his wife Deacon was it
wasn't that Korea shows deacon wasn't a
career I look out the window he's like
this and he's talking like the other
football players like I can't talk about
it and she goes is my through grits I
know when he was a baby
I got like Al Green she's exactly like
Al Green if you go to the parallel they
still know me holdin court about this
he's wheeling little tiny like yeah good
wide roll the sports dolphin shorts oh
she's getting down this dog is uh it's
just you know I guess so Kelly scratches
right now on the desk j @j more 37 on
twitter happy birthday sir thank you
buddy
Congrats on party boat on crash seven
years old I've got to give your dog back
to you alright cuz I'm gonna have a
little one-on-one time with
we are two days away two days away from
Mayweather McGregor and you can get the
pay-per-view right here on DirecTV and
you could go right now and text event 2
2 2 3 3 2 2 as Irv is doing what he
thinks one of these guys is gonna do
here well Greg go to DIRECTV comm or
text event 2 2 to 3 3 to 2 it's
available in high definition on channel
123 and standard def on 124 don't forget
to weigh in again and cast your vote
using hashtag mayweather FTW or mcgregor
FTW the hashtag in front of it or just
tell us who you thinks gonna win it Rich
Eisen show no matter what Michael
Irvin's doing peripherally you're used
to it we would hook you up with Jay Jay
over there since you hadn't seen him in
a long yeah I haven't and I love Jay man
Jay's a funny guide man and I'm home I'm
tired from that looks bad I know I know
I was about to say you don't want to
tell yourself out we got you for the
rest of this show yeah there's a
punching bag out there we're gonna walk
out there and have you hit the punching
bag and see bag man I got some things
some people okay
that I want to in my mind put in the bag
and why I get hurt that bad is that
Alvin Harper bro good things to me but
there's some other people are good
things to me by the way the two names on
NFL gameday morning as you know
on Seabourn Island we love doing that
oh my go about how you didn't like to
share that with Alvin Harper we have fun
with the we have fun with it who do you
think is gonna win Mayweather McGregor
what do you thaw earth what do you think
I'm a huge MMA fan you know I love it I
go I love Dana White I called Dana go to
fights with him and everything hanging
out with him in Dallas I was his
security as he walked in and out of the
ring you know is that right oh yeah you
know Dana was messing with me some yeah
believe it I got Michael urban is my
security Michael well I just love to do
man I love what he's done with UFC I
wish I'm serious I know I believe
Mayweather a win the fight but I would
love to see Connor win I would love to
see Connor win and then we get to do it
again and I'm amazed to me it's just
just it's right up there with football
for me
I know when I see it I'm going to see
something every match I don't care who
you are I don't care how great you are
you don't even have to be that great I'm
still going to see something and it's
just I'm just I'm addicted to it what's
the poll question results right now
because you basically just turned but I
think everybody's gonna be saying is
that I think Mayweather is gonna win but
I would like McGregor to win it look
we're asking Mike who are you rooting
for so it's still 67% Conor McGregor
that's a scary question for me again
Here I am I'm a brother and you know
there's some people that don't like
McGregor you know like my on Mayweather
and by me saying that I want I want
McGregor win because I'm UFC Fan I can
lose some of my arm where they call
Brotherhood or whatever they calls that
I mean as dark as I am I don't know how
I can lose from my Brotherhood you don't
come much blacker than me but UFC you
know I want to see and promotes and push
forward the UFC and speaking of that I'm
so hurt guys yes I'm so hurt by John
Jones man I'm praying I'm praying that
that somehow someway this second sample
comes back different
though 99.99999% times they don't but
I'm just so hurt I'm hurt for him you
know not this it hurt by a man I heard
four i jo i I kind of joked but tweeting
this out when I heard about it they
should just let Jon Jones and Brock
Lesnar take whatever the hell they want
raka do whatever the hell you want and
get out there and just cut the pretense
here because I mean how many times is
corn you're gonna get his title back
they haven't announced that yeah yeah
you know I wonder - oh so with some of
this this stuff is so it's so crazy out
here now and we just steroids what it
used to be and what we used to think of
steroids and and and what people are
trying to do now to get any kind of age
I mean there's one thing
performance-enhancing saying I'm trying
to take an unfair advantage but
everybody's doing all kinds of things to
get in edge you know but but and we
don't I don't know what's banned if I
was in the NFL right now I would be
worried because you don't know what
supplements what hats what being such
that's on you
rights on you to know these thing right
so we look at them and we said John
Jones once we take a step I don't know
if he's necessarily taking steroids but
he may be taking something that's
obviously he's saying something's
getting in his system that's on the
banned list so yeah it's just it's not
you know I think steroids as those
bodybuilders guys guys biggest muscles
in the world it just I don't see that on
John Jones you know what I mean I don't
see that on he wants to take in
something but yeah to do something that
that's band on that band listen I just
feel bad I don't want to take a break so
not only can you catch your breath but
we're gonna go out there and we're gonna
hit that speed bag that del 2fo you've
been really go yeah and then we're gonna
come back I want to hit you on the
cowboys and what's going on with Zeke I
had a mitt and that very seat the day
that got suspended
yeah and I want to hear your two cents
on that subject and then I got forced in
its own that okay very good that's next
with Michael Irvin you're in there Josh
you've won four four
all right we're in the AT&T thoroughfare
look at how many people are lining up
right here then take a swak at what Dell
2fo has been training for all week
reminder that everybody text the word
event 2 2 to 3 3 to 2 DIRECTV calm right
now to by the McGregor Mayweather fight
on DirecTV pay-per-view two days from
now
ok woman sister there you gotta be hard
you guys we could see it all right
you're you're punched is up to 7 2007 38
8 oh please no best man out Michael tell
to foe
here we go it's 600 going through it
don't go to it now
Oh stuck so I guess 40 going through it
one more time
I did catch her in the right way
five six seven
all right we just hit the punching bag
out in the AT&T thoroughfare Brockman
lost one of his man bracelets off of his
uh no your your you've got you give your
bracelet one everywhere
I haven't trained at all and I did
better than Dell to foe just a little
just a little good at one point I got up
to 704 that's great one of your heads
got 703 that was particularly I can't
wait to tell all the guys when I see
them later at the NFL Network up front
that I'm a emceeing later on with you
and Marshall and every yellow jacket we
have - Dion on the stage today
I won't I won't mention it was a great
job ultimately I had more than 704 73
but you beat all of those guys that was
his second punch just for the record
everybody I got to make that clear
punching is great my pillows my telecom
promo code rich get the best pillows on
the market call 861 three five nine
seven four drop the promo code there
four pack special 50% off and free
shipping on to my pillow premium pillows
and to go anywhere pillows my my code
name is rich again at my pillow calm all
right you said you had four cents on his
e kill Elliot what are those four cents
well we're talking you know first let me
tell you what I would I would I hate
right now and what it's become you know
and I've been in that position before
and I'm in this job and I when I was in
that position I watched people on this
job do it to me and they're now they're
doing it to him any little thing around
Ezekiel Elliott he becomes a ratings
baby you know soda teas
next up find out what else is going on
with Ezekiel Elliott so we're gonna
physique you Eliot Spitzer on the side
while he's driving down the street who
next up find out what's going on with
the zq alien which is cause which is why
I'm wondering why he's showing up you
know on Lake Lewisville
absolutely absolutely I understand
officer and I'm gonna tell you this from
from experience that age is hard man
it's just flat-out hard to see things
that clearly when he when you're saying
okay I'm not going to do anything wrong
in his mind I haven't done anything
wrong
and so now the same fight that we see on
a football field
that we love him for on the football
field that reptilian brain that brings
out the guy that runs right into km
Chancellor on the football field you're
going to get some of him on off the
football field he says you know I ain't
done anything wrong you know III I don't
care what anybody said I'm not going to
stop living my life and I'm not gonna
I'm gonna make sure I don't do anything
wrong here so he doesn't see just
hanging out looks bad
like we all look at well the optics I'll
just repeat what I said the other day
the optics is just that that's the
lesser of the problem the bigger problem
is that when he's agent the whatever
lawyers he's got on staff the Union his
teammates and whatever all want him back
and they're trying their hardest to get
him back he's putting himself in a
situation it may be it may have been a
beautiful day on the lake and no one
else was around but you never know who
might be out there with bad intentions
oh and suddenly he's in a situation he
can't control well and that's the big
concern that's it that's a concern any
rich that's not isolated to the lake
that I don't care if he's walking in the
grocery store the same situation is
viable I don't I don't care if he's
trying to get to the star to practice
that same situation is viable because we
have people out here that want to try to
get ahead and the only way they seek it
in the head is by trying to sue somebody
so they'll start something because they
know you have your back against the wall
these are the realities man and that's
those are the things that I worry about
more than anything I worry more about
someone provoking a situation honestly
then I worry about Zeke calls in a
situation I've got about four minutes
left in the entire show we had Emmitt in
that chair the day he got suspended and
you know you know he and Emmitt are are
still working
on a relationship essentially he
basically said that that Zeke has got a
you know he and they have to have a
trust before they and I even brought up
I'm like well
Ervin Dez kind of hit it off right from
the get-go that's what I'm asking cuz he
said that he would reach out to him if
or if Zeke reached out to him he would
definitely talk to him have you reached
out to his I talked to Zeke yeah tell
him right first of all I'm trying to
keep his spirits up man when I see them
I saw him I saw him at practice the
other day you know I just say man you
know you know we need you now we need
you you know and I go at them from that
standpoint I don't you know I don't come
and tell me you got to do this man you
can't do it you can't do it you know I
try to talk to him about we need them
period we need you a lot of people
around here that needs you and depending
on you and when I always see my he has
this big old back I mean his backs like
two of me and always grabbing us but his
back is caring all over Cowboys and the
Dallas hopes right on it now can you
carry now hug on him but but i but I try
to use it and do it in a positive way
you know what I mean and talk to him
what he has ahead of him and instead of
the things that he's dealing with right
now like hey we need you man we love you
justice you know we need basically
saying we need you to make the right
decisions to be here for all of us
because we do need them I don't want to
hit them with all mean you can't do this
me you can't do it he's 22 years old
he's 22 years old and there's some
things this kid is going to get out he's
going to be around his friends they're
going to go out and have fun and and and
we can't stop that no one can stop that
I just hope that he has the right people
around him that when situations come
about and people are trying to provoke
them provoke him that they step in and
make sure that's not the case
two minutes left here so let's say he
does mix miss the six games does that
does that see how it's not going to miss
six cases be real here there's no way to
NFL it's going to lay out the first six
game suspension on their whole new
policy that they bragged about coming in
with and upholding and now all of a
sudden is zzq Elliott and and they'd
reduce it the first time I think I think
they don't want to do
with the backlash of the national media
by doing that because it's Ezekiel aid
in the Dallas Cowboys and Jerry Jones
that's just a reality so how does it
affect their season well you know when I
was over to talk to our coach Dooley
receive his coaching and and dads and
all the guys other day you know I said
they'd help I'm expecting you guys to
pick it up on the outside for those
first six game they said we already
talked about that in the meeting room
Michael that we have to pick it up we
got a little Switzer coming in the guys
look here they got dropped and we're
going to put him in with with Beasley
and we're going to do some things in the
passing game that could help open up
things and open up running lanes for the
Darren McFadden and the Morris and all
those guys to help create something for
them that they proudly don't need to
create that they don't really need to
create physique love having you on man
I love when you come down here so I mean
I love it - man I wish we had more time
to talk I know that we need like an hour
by ourself you turn by ourselves
Julianne's me and do that rich and get
deep in all things and everything man to
talk about how we're gonna make this
world better okay Michael Irvin here
want to thank Jay Mohr Alexandra
Daddario Anquan Boldin was on an hour
one he was great and and William H Macy
tomorrow it is Dana White on this show
to kick things off that's on greatest
promote in the world right there Dana
way that's my dude man Nnamdi Asomugha
the actor will be here no I'm not
and Larry Merchant in studio thanks for
watching and consuming this Thursday
edition of the Rich Eisen show will do
lies in overtime with her next the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that download our app please
just if if it's a memory thing just
delete other refs you don't need those
apps this app the Rich Eisen show up you
need that